hey what's going on YouTube ah uh huh
have you guys are wondering why I let it
be the [ __ ] it's I just do I don't know
I know a lot of you guys have been
asking about the inspiration behind the
stuff that I write so does y'all want to
know I didn't tell you
now the person in this kit that I use
obviously is Khalif because this kid was
actually written for him now Cleef has a
huge and ginormous fro if y'all can't
tell but for some damn reason every time
somebody wants to talk to him the first
thing they're gonna say it is cannot
touch over now understand what the
fascination with it he's tall his hairs
largest vehicle he looks like that like
a q-tip uh-huh but here's the thing that
you should ask yourself do they want you
to touch it now I'm not sure that any of
you ever care to ask but I'm pretty sure
he gets annoyed every time somebody
wants to be like never and of course I
had to have one of my favorite guys to
ever be on my videos a batch which up
that you guys popping oh man king batch
on vine one of the funniest dudes out
there but he of course brought his own
comedic style to my video which made it
that much better so here comes the
bloopers and the BTS check out patran
you don't tell me what to do
I tell you what soompi yo look something
my son why yo this is real yeah but you
get that for hate your mother
this [ __ ] crazy and action
let me touch your fro let me touch your
from let me touch your from let me touch
your fro other dear small one
let me touch your from
yo action like my comfort zone down a
little water there a catch-all throw
okay
showers ain't a star okay yeah wash my
car bro I'll rub those nipples hey yo
it's true in black move like force
that's something at all I don't like the
fact that this was body my body's in the
same clips it's like a lucky Hydroxycut
commercial ha ha ha Hydroxycut you even
turn black right after I once was Asian
now I'm streaming Danny yeah you always
cool in by yourself
ah dad Joe go on without me ok [ __ ]
shut up